I just got off work and I'm still kind
of at work I'm just kind of taking my
break right now so
hi baby that's taking his break to take
his shahada Allah
ain't nothing more important yes sir bro
all right so I'm going to pull up a uh
little
screen share here can you guys see that
yeah I can see it yes all right perfect
I tied this one up myself because I
think it's a little easier to follow
than the website so you're just gonna
repeat after me actually before we do
that I have to ask you some questions
so first I'm just gonna ask you a few
questions about what you believe just to
make sure they're in line with what
Muslims believe okay all right I promise
you it's nothing difficult it's very
basic so first and foremost do you
believe that there's only one God worthy
of worship and he has no Partners no
Associates no father no Mom no Sons no
daughters
there is only one God
perfect only ever been one God
alhamdulillah beautiful and do you
believe in the angels
do I believe in the Angels yeah like the
angels that Allah describes in the Quran
oh of course beautiful and do you
believe in the prophets and The
Messengers that God sent
peace be upon them I do beautiful and do
you believe in the Revelation the
revelations that God sent with these
prophets like the original Torah the
original gospel the Quran and so on and
so forth I do
beautiful and do you believe in Divine
decree from Allah
I do
and do you believe in the day of
judgment I do believe in the day of
judgment beautiful all right my man and
with that being said inshallah just
repeat after me in Arabic and then we're
going to say it in English
hadu Allah
[Music]
illa Allah
wa
wa
[Music]
Anna Anna
muhammadan muhammadan
rasulu rasulo
now you're gonna repeat after me in
English I bear witness I bear witness
that there is none worthy of worship
that there is none worthy of worship
except for Allah except for Allah and I
bear witness and I bear witness that the
prophet Muhammad that the prophet
Muhammad is the servant is the servant
and messenger of Allah and messenger of
Allah
foreign
so how do you feel my man you seem very
knowledgeable on Islam already I do I
can't tell you how much research I've
been doing just for the past year
um on Islam uh I'm you know and that I
came in when I came into the chat uh
last time you guys did that live stream
I was there I still had some questions
uh one of somebody from that chat
actually reached out to me on Twitter
um and he's actually answered he's been
great he's answered a lot of questions
that I had
um I still have a few questions but um
you know I just I'm just trying to take
it how I you know take it as it goes
take it easy I'm trying to learn
everything I can as much as I can you
know because so I can I wanna I wanna
please Allah as much as I can
may Allah bless the brother that helped
you out on Twitter and answering the
questions if you have any if you have
any questions for us now you know feel
free to ask I do
um as far as you know because I got
there was a guy I don't know if you guys
remember
um there you guys did a live stream with
young Don you know what I'm talking
about yes we do how do we forget bro
there was a there was a brother on there
a Muslim brother on there that you guys
had I don't I cannot remember his name
at all
um but he has a website and he actually
uh I guess he sends free qurans and I
got the Quran from him
um and I I you know
um and you know through my research you
know of doing Islam I I I've heard that
there's different translations you know
as far as each Quran goes so I'm just
trying to see is there a better Quran
that I should be reading rather than the
one that he sent he sent me which one
did he send you
um it's called the I don't have it it's
in it's in in my uh in my story it's
called The Noble the translation of the
noble Quran
yeah so is it like um is it old old
English like ye and thou and all that
stuff or is it modern I think it's
modern I'm pretty sure it's modern you
know
yeah as long as it's modern and you can
understand what it's saying you should
be good obviously there are going to be
some words that you just cannot
Translate into Arabic so if you're
curious about adverse you know feel free
to ask you know uh or anybody else will
break it down for you but you'll be fine
inshallah and bro even if it was Old
English you'd be fun like as long as you
took your time like the message will
still get through the first Quran that I
read was an Old English man
and so so and as far as I guess you know
praying goes do I do I need to get a a
specific rug from somewhere or how how
do I necessarily go about doing that
right if you want a rug we'll send you a
rug but you don't need a specific drug
man yeah yeah okay I I didn't yeah I'm
sorry I'm not you know I hope that
wasn't like an offensive question
I'm new to this I'm trying to I'm trying
to do it to the best of my abilities the
best that I can
um
um you can pray anywhere as long as it's
clean you can put a towel down you can
pray on the floor if it's clean you're
going to inshaallah and you're don't
worry you're definitely not offensive my
brother we're very very happy to have
you with us I appreciate you um and one
thing uh on you I I just want to say uh
thank you because
out of everyone here you know no offense
to anyone but everyone here I feel like
I connect with you more because you are
a Reverb correct
um but you know not not to say that I
necessarily I've necessarily never
claimed to be you know I grew up in a
Christian household so to speak I never
but you know I was it was never forced
upon me nor did I ever necessarily you
know claimed to be Christian or anything
like that but just just me hearing all
the live streams and hearing you talk I
just feel like I connect so much with
you
um and I and I appreciate everything and
everything you've ever said because it
really just it it's really you that's
really drawn me towards Islam like just
hearing just hearing everything you've
been through and stuff like that it
really has helped me and I appreciate
you bro I appreciate you man may Allah
bless you because
some people think that I speak too slow
that I bring no value at all so dude
they just you know people that just want
to start a pot you know it's it's yeah
I'm grateful I'm grateful to hear that
man I'm I'm uh very happy to see you as
a Muslim now oh I'm happy to be Muslim
now um and then last question if you
know I don't know if you guys have any
kind of contact that I can have maybe on
hand just in case I have do you have any
more questions obviously I can't ask
anything right now because break's about
to be up and I gotta get back but I will
I'm more than likely we'll have some
more questions you know as I continue my
journey and continue learning if I could
have a some sort of way to reach you
guys whether it be Twitter or an email
yeah so you could do email or I mean if
you have Instagram as well you get the
Amazon uh DM Plus on Instagram
but either way man I mean we can get you
a direct information and we can go from
there inshallah and
um also in the future
um two little notes we are working on
the three Muslims website we're
developing it if you go to it now it'll
be the same thing that it's been for
like the last year but we are we're
working on it so Allah it's going to be
very very nice and inshallah we're going
to include a section four reverse people
just come to Islam we were curious about
Islam and all that stuff and very
special content on there yeah
when did we say this man I uh I I
reached out to some actually I asked
some people reach out to me to help out
and uh alhamdulillah we have an amazing
team working on it uh web web developers
and web designers are amazing
um
I can help too I'm actually in school
for cyber security so you know I know
really yeah
definitely be willing to help out
I'm here man I'm here for you guys and I
appreciate it
is on uh sorry to cut you off no you're
fine but on my Instagram I actually did
a live and there's his brother on the
that I had um he came onto the stream
and he's studying the same thing and he
was saying like how important this is to
be able to protect yourself online oh
yeah at some point we wanted to bring
him on but that would be dope if we
brought both of you on so y'all could
share this beneficial knowledge to
people because it's things that I
actually never really thought about too
in-depth you know you hear like oh
change your password oh like be be a
little bit more secure in what you do
here and there like don't use this for
your password or something but
I guess it's a lot more deeper than what
we think you you would be surprised
there's a there's it it is as you know
the internet technology going man it's
it's going to be a necessity and it's
very a necessity to be secure if you're
going to be online if you're going to be
using a phone because I mean there's
there's there's an attack you know a
Cyber attack every single minute you
know that I mean just just in the you
know the world alone there's over over a
billion dollars lost in just cyber tags
and everything else I mean just recently
where I am they took out a power grid
you know and we we were out we were
there without power for for days so it's
it's uh it's definitely a growing a
growing problem and you know I would and
I would love to you know help every
that's that's pretty much what I plan to
do once I finish just to help everybody
that I can be secure because there's so
many people that are just freely online
without you know knowing how to be
secure you know especially especially
for my Muslim brothers because we're
always under attack it seems like
every time I look up man it's just
something I I you know it's it's it's
crazy
brother Aquila said cyberji had loading
hello that's beautiful okay bro um
that would be amazing
oh yeah man like I would love to I would
appreciate you guys man I appreciate
everything you're doing thank you for
having me here today man thank you for
doing the shahada with me and everything
honestly it's our pleasure like I know
you might be grateful but honestly I
think we should be the Grateful ones
because Allah has blessed us with this
opportunity so honestly I'm I'm very
very honored that you decided to join us
and take your shahada with us out of All
Peoples may Allah bless you immensely
thank you appreciate you guys of course
my brother get in touch with us
inshallah
sorry I mean but I'm gonna I'm gonna
send you guys a because I don't have
Instagram I don't I don't do Instagram
that is that's true
I'm gonna hit you guys on Twitter if you
want to send me an email or send me an
email or if you just want to do Twitter
that's fine but yeah I only I only have
Twitter I don't do Facebook Instagram
all that you know Twitter's not too
secure but those are definitely just for
security they're terrible terrible man
are you making me reconsider having an
Instagram bro you know
you know see you know to to help you
guys out just to see if your email has
ever been compromised phone numbers
anything you guys have you can there's a
way to look all that up to see if it's
ever been compromised if ever people
ever sold your information anything like
that so like I said I'll get at you guys
on Twitter and we can we can go from
there
yeah
go go to work man we don't want you to
be leaving
of course
we'll talk soon
what a beautiful brother may Allah bless
him I mean bro I mean um one more
announcement we're also inshallah very
soon learning launching a uh the three
Muslims Discord I know everyone's been
asking forever so alhamdulillah we got
Brothers to work on that as well so
inshallah the three muslims.com will be
updated soon and the Discord will be
updated soon so inshallah will have a
place to send our River brothers and
sisters so when they start practicing it
won't just be us it'll be the whole
Community inshallah backing them there
for them insha Allah so make Dua Allah
man I had no idea